let's have a think about this now before
we have a go at this question i want to
pose a similar but simpler question to
you okay anytime you have these squares
you've got to be super careful there's a
big trick involved and i'll tell you why
in a second let's just consider this
p squared equals 25
okay now
before what we've been doing is saying
look what's what's happened to this side
right like what do we have before y over
four equals some stuff right what's
happened to this we need to work out a
way to reverse that right so in this
case that's division by four so we
multiplied by four right
so you look at this guy and you're like
what has been done to it and how do i
reverse that the answer is it was
squared what's the reverse of squaring
the answer is kind of taking the square
root now you've got a square button well
you calculated it it's actually next to
your fraction button okay
if what you did was say
take the square root of this side
that's a p squared and take the square
root of this side
so far so good right like it's an
equation these two things are equal so i
did the same thing to both sides
so far so good
what does this equal the square root of
p squared
it should just be p right like it's
cancelled out the the square and the
square root they've undone each other
and the square root of 25 is is fine
it's the number that you multiply by
itself to give you 25 okay so you arrive
at this right now this is tricky because
we said that when you arrive at a
solution it's kind of like a key right
and you'll know you've got it right if
it unlocks your original equation okay
so let's have a look
let's put it back in what happens on the
left hand side i've got five
times five what's that
it works so you're like okay so far so
good
this is an answer right the problem is
this is wrong
it's wrong
why is it wrong
it's wrong in a particular way
very very tricky this is why i wanted to
draw attention to this question in
particular okay
it's not that p equals five isn't a
solution
v equals five is a solution
the problem is
there's another one
there's another solution to this
equation uh we were used to what do we
get over here you know when i had y
equals 5
1 4 sorry is 5 on 3 8 and then we got
one answer and one answer only at the
end okay there's no other number that
you can put into here and it will unlock
so if you like this is kind of a lock
that has only one key
but this up here this equation
has more than one solution or another
way of saying it um this lot can be
opened
by more than one key
now i wonder if anyone can see what the
other key is
you can always test it out couldn't you
you can put it in for example if i put
10 into there i'd get 10 times 10 10
times 10 is
a hundred so it's not one of them
well you could save five but that'd be
the same key wouldn't it i guess it'd be
holding the same key twice
of course they're both gonna unlock but
you really only have one key that works
right
one kind of key
there's another number there's another
number that i can stick in here
and it'll work it'll unlock
tricky
it's not imaginary it's a number you're
very familiar with
seven
you can test them out if you're guessing
you can test them out you can put one in
there you can put seven
i'll give you a clue i'll give you a
clue
um this number right this number here
it's a it's a positive number right
5 5 squared gives you 25 okay but you
know about other numbers not just
positive ones that you can still square
right
for instance
if i said totally separate theme if i
said negative 3
i could square that right if i square it
that means negative 3
times negative 3. all right hold on we
know numbers is integers negative 9.
there's
yeah yeah these two negatives right they
negative kind of means opposite right so
it's like you you change direction but
you change direction again so you're
going back in the way that you were in
the first place that's positive nine
right so if you take a negative number
you square it
you get a positive one at the other end
so how does that relate to this well for
that one i'll put it in the calculator
it says negative
probably because you type this
is that correct yeah yeah so that's
they've looked at this and they've said
that's negative three times three
because you squared the three you didn't
square the negative three
see this is why you've got to be careful
with calculators right yeah you haven't
put brackets in these are different
yeah yeah see see what i mean by you
can't just use a calculator and expect
it to you know give you the right answer
every time it'll give you the answer
that you ask for if you ask for this
it'll give you a negative nine but we're
talking about this
we're gonna say something tom
okay negative five negative five
negative five question mark
well we can test it out can't we we can
go back to this first line
and we can chuck it in what do you get
you get negative five times negative
five
right
the negatives cancel which gives you a
positive and then the fives
sure enough they give you 25.
it works
so hold on let's just
pedal back a second what have we just
included this equation
is weird
this equation
has not just one solution but two
two keys that unlock it okay
that's why we give this equation a
special kind of name it's a name you
might have heard before okay this is
called
a quadratic equation
okay now if you've never heard before
that's okay right i just want you to
have the word in your head you'll hear
it a bit more in the future
the reason why it's a quadratic what
makes this a quadratic is this guy that
guy up there right have a look at your
other questions the earlier ones
question one question two can you see
they don't have these powers involved
there are no indices right when you add
them in
particularly when you've got a power of
two you get a quadratic if you had a
power of three you get what we call a
cubic power of four aquatic and they
keep on having special names after that
okay
it's got two solutions now how can i fix
this up because we arrived here and then
we said hooray i'm done okay i'll show
you how to fix it up
let's pedal back and get all of this
stuff off the board
okay come back to the beginning with me
now
we said that we should take the square
root of both sides okay
the reason why that led us to problems
is because actually actually
squaring
is
not
the exact opposite
of taking the square root uh yeah
okay that's so important i want you to
write it down because it's a big deal
and people get very confused about this
for years to come okay
if you want to undo squaring you can't
simply take the square root okay it
doesn't give you back the real answer it
only gives you back half the answer okay
what you really have to do is
here instead of taking the square root i
have to take
plus or minus
the square root
that will give me the two solutions
right so the square root of 25
it's still 5.
sorry just skipping down here
so the way i read this is p equals plus
or minus
five it's kind of my shorthand
for saying two answers at once okay
we're kind of simple your calculator
doesn't have it because calculator can't
deal with this kind of thing uh it can
only deal with a single number but you
guys can deal with more
okay so
be super careful with these um plus or
minus 5 is the answer now as if that was
not confusing enough let's have a look
at the previous question
uh we haven't even we haven't even sold
this question actually
um maybe we should solve this question
first before we have a look and see
now what should i do okay i'll come back
to my original question right
um if i want p on its own right i should
take the square root but what else
should i have in front
i should have this i should have this
plus or minus shouldn't i okay so i'm
going to say p equals plus or minus
that's the first thing that i write
and then i take the square root of
whatever's on that right hand side which
is 9 over 64.
okay
now i know 964 is a fraction
but i can consider the top and bottom
separately okay
i'll have that plus or minus out the
front don't forget to write it don't
stop writing it as if you wrote it once
and that's enough
it carries all the way through okay then
you're going to have the square root of
9 on the top and the square root of 64
on the bottom and we know what those are
what's the square root of 9.
square root of nine
it's a positive number it's three it's
three
oh sorry and then the square root of 64
the number that multiplies myself to
give you 64.
i can do all the squares can't i one
squared is one two squared is four three
squared is eight nine
eight
sixteen twenty-five thirty-six
forty-nine
64. right you should know your um it
really helps to know
your times tables and therefore your
squares okay they're very helpful
numbers
that's it there's the answer
plus or minus
3 8. um if you wanted to write what is
actually equal to sometimes they'll say
there's negative 3 8 or
3 8. that's that's what it's shorthand
for but obviously this is much quicker
to write than this okay